hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back I'm foreigner and today we
have some interesting information that I
didn't even think was gonna come up this
was found on the for honor Amino app if
you're one of the og subs you remember I
did a sponsorship with them by the way
really great app it's basically reddit
but with different communities and I'm
in the for honor Amino app and someone
talked about the reworks for warden and
Valkyrie and some of the changes that
are going to be in it so as always like
the view if you do enjoy a subscriber
who knew I cover the informational side
of for honor that being balance changes
leaks patch notes hero updates all the
type of stuff and with that let's get
started with today's video just in case
for copyright issues I'm not going to
show this on screen we're just going to
talk about it while I read it I will
link it in the description if you do
want to follow along with what I'm
saying or you want to take a look at
this yourself it's all did fine and
dandy it'll be in the description down
below and as well there's going to be
timestamps in the description if you
want to see your specific character that
being warden or Valkyrie and they will
be on screen now if you want to skip to
those parts of the video if you want a
specific hero but that let's get started
with warden so first up is warden like I
said and the first thing that it says is
that zone attack can now be chained into
another heavy which is really
interesting I don't know any single zone
attack in the game that can be chained
into another attack shortly afterwards
so that's pretty interesting and
crushing counter strike and no longer
guarantees a shoulder bash but you can
still link into it if you feel like it
you get your second top leg guaranteed
after a successful crush encounter so
that's also pretty cool it makes the
crushing counter strike I feel a little
bit less viable so that more people can
dodge out of it which is interesting for
shoulder bash it says now links from
forward dash at 100 milliseconds charge
time from the maximum charge is at 1,000
milliseconds the maximum charge hits at
300 milliseconds and is now down from
400 milliseconds and it can be canceled
into a feint at any point in time before
the movement starts if you have up to
100 milliseconds after the release the
guard break button to fainted that
basically means if you're a little bit
confused is that you have a little bit
less time to do your mind game such as
going for the shoulder bash fainting it
into nothing or fainting it into a guard
break next up is for heavy finishers and
now the top unblockable hits at 1100
milliseconds it's six stamina cost and
deals the same amount of damage side
heavy finishers and I'll do a 40 damage
and cost six stamina cost I don't know
why that is called six because most
moves cost a lot more I feel like this
should cost a little bit more than 6 but
maybe this is a little bit wrong
side lights are now 500 milliseconds
down from 600 milliseconds and the
second top light in the light chain
attack is now 400 milliseconds so making
his light attacks a little bit faster
warden also has a new move coming and
there is no name for this but it just
says it's a forward - and heavy it is a
20 stamina cost move deals 20 damage 500
millisecond attack and it starts at 300
milliseconds in the - forward movement
always hits from the left and chains
into heavy finishers and now the sprint
to tech and also change into heavy
finishers as well see how worden is
possibly going to be getting a new move
if this thing holds up and is actually
correct and like I said this is going to
be a - forward heavy warden I believe
does not have a - forward move so this
is gonna be a little bit interesting and
it's always going to be coming from the
left side and it deals 20 damage and
it's a 500 millisecond attack as stated
previously moving on we have Valkyrie
and she is a new chain and that is the
light heavy heavy so now she has that
different type of chain the sweet patek
now replaces a chain finisher 500
milliseconds and now performed by
pressing guard break and then sweep in
multiple targets friendly and enemy
which I believe is pretty normal from
the base version because you could sweep
opponents and your teammates when you do
that sweep this is also pretty cool that
you can actually now it use the sweep
after a chain finisher instead of just
going for the guard break and then the
sweep and stuff like that so that's
pretty interesting as well on top of
that sweep Patek SAR also no longer
guaranteed after a throw anymore and the
chain attacks from a successful show of
crush now come out at 300 milliseconds
instead of 500 milliseconds which
guarantees a light attack so basically
if you happen to do the shield crush you
can get a guaranteed light and then
possibly follow into a different combo
maybe another sweep again stuff like
that on top of that heavy openers can be
canceled or followed up by a shield
crush but you cannot do a finisher into
a shield crush it is only these starters
that you can cancel this into a shield
crush shield crush is no longer
guaranteed by the enemy being hit by one
of your heavies or by blocking it and
for shield tackle charged or non charged
gives the same effect which doesn't
knock down opponent's shield tackle can
now be fainted from entry loop in the
beginning of a strike no longer possible
to cancel shield tackle with back dodged
so this one's a little bit confusing it
seems like you may have to commit if you
do the shield tackle I hope that's not
the case because then that would leave a
lot of outreach players a little bit on
the on the slow side so it
like you'd have to cancel shield tackle
at the beginning of the move as opposed
to maybe halfway through which is pretty
interesting and for her throw they
removed the charge from the valkyries
head but now it's just a normal front
throw and no longer guarantees a sweep
so it looks like they removed her head
but as well which is pretty interesting
for this rework and as it says it no
longer guarantees a sweep so you can't
get that and then get the guaranteed
heavy right after it the alight openers
range has been slightly increased
probably to get that little bit of
distance because of how big her weapon
is and her finisher light attacks are
now 500 milliseconds down from 600 so a
100 milliseconds quicker her side leg
finishers now have a special hit
reaction that pushed the opponent on hit
and stagger opponents if they hit the
wall superior block lights follow-up as
now unblockable which is really
interesting and shoulder pin now starts
as a chain starter shoulder pin now
starts as a chain starter but can only
be only be changed with the shield crush
and now guaranteed on a successful dodge
block for her zone attack edit a 200
millisecond fame clip after the second
strike of the zone attack the second hit
of the zone attack cannot be canceled
into shield crush at 400 milliseconds
the second hit of the zone attack is now
feint able at 400 milliseconds to
prevent flicker any second hit of the
zone is now 800 milliseconds instead of
700 basically what that means is that
the second hit of her zone is going to
be a little bit slower but you can feint
it and then also cancel it into a shoe
of crush along for even more mix-up
potential and then for her attack damage
rebalancing which is the last part about
her the heavy opener now does 28 damage
up from 25 damage so a little bit more
damage on the heavy opener the heavy
finisher now doesn't increased 5 more
damage at 35 instead of 30 the shoulder
pin now does 20 health and 15 bleed from
what it used to be was 1 health and 15
bleed at so now the shoulder pin is
going to be a little bit more viable now
and the light openers now do 15 damage
up from 12 so basically her heavy opener
or heavy finisher or shoulder pin and
the light opener now do a little bit
more increased damage and that guy is
gonna be the end of the video today if
you guys didn't enjoy that let me know
what you guys think in the comments
below whether you think the warden
rework is cool the Valkyrie work both of
them whatever one you're most excited
for maybe some changes that you're a
little bit worried about stuff like that
what that guys like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational side of foreigner like
I said that happens to do it that
happens to be balance changes leaks hero
updates all that type of stuff new
events
balance changes like I said my two most
recent videos will be on screen if you
guys want to check that out when that
guys so we have a great rest your day
thanks for watching the video and peace
out